la grande montaison des saumons
socailles dans les rivières de la côte
ouest est un spectacle unique au monde
et de plus en plus on comprend l'apport
de ces poissons à la santé des
écosystèmes riverains mais les
changements climatiques entre autres
viennent bouleverser cette équilibre
millénaire
c'est un des spectacles de la nature les
plus extraordinaires qu'on puisse voir
tous les quatrains la rivière Adams en
Colombie-Britannique el théâtre d'une
montaison de saumon soccase s'empare
ils sont des millions à revenir ici pour
se reproduire au même endroit qui les a
vu naître et qui va les voir mourir
à l'automne 2022 la représentation tant
attendue ne s'est pas déroulée comme
prévu
le plus célèbre de tous les salmonités
du Pacifique n'est pas au rendez-vous
depuis des semaines la
Colombie-Britannique bat des records de
chaleur
et il ne pleut pas
le niveau des rivières est bas et la
température de l'eau est élevée du
jamais vu
les gens ne comprennent pas l'impact
qu'à la température sur les poissons
notre première question n'arrivera ici
c'est mais où sont les poissons
on était un peu découragés si on avait
entendu
qu'il y en avait beaucoup moins qui
attendaient
une énorme quantité revenir comme ça
arrive normalement tous les quatre ans
et maintenant on hésite entre dire
qu'ils seront en retard et dire qu'ils
ne viendront peut-être pas
[Musique]
30 septembre 2022
c'est l'ouverture du festival salut au
socaï
durant trois semaines des visiteurs de
partout sur la planète convergent vers
la rivière-adams pour observer la plus
grande montaison de saumon rouge en
Amérique du Nord
un phénomène que la science a encore du
mal à comprendre
les saumon frais toujours ici mais au
quatrains leur population explose
littéralement ça fait partie de leur
signe
au bord de l'eau tête d'anilook explique
au touristes le cycle de vie des
socailles
quand ils arrivent ici la femelle se met
en quête d'un endroit où pondre ses œufs
une année comme cette année on peut
s'attendre à un demi million de saumons
si vous êtes patient et que vous ne
lâchez pas la rivière des yeux c'est ce
que vous verrez
l'histoire débute et se termine ici
après leur naissance dans la rivière
Adams les jeunes se caillent passent de
une à deux années en eau douce
il migrent ensuite vers le Pacifique
pour s'alimenter durant deux ou trois
ans
puis leur horloge biologique sonne
quelque part entre mai et juillet et
ensuite il maigre de retour à
l'embouchure du trésor
au cours de ce processus il change
d'apparence c'est physiologique
savez-vous pourquoi pourquoi d'après
vous change-t-il de couleur et de forme
des idées
les changements physiologiques s'opèrent
au moment où les soccailles commencent
leur migration de retour pour se
reproduire il passe alors du bleu
argenté au rouge orangé
cette nouvelle couleur s'explique en
raison de leur régime alimentaire dans
l'océan qui est riche en caroténoïdes
les mêmes pigments qui donnent leur
couleur aux carottes
à mesure que les saumons approchent de
leur frayères en rivière ces pigments
rouges stockés dans leur chair sont
transférés vers leurs écailles ce qui
les rend plus visibles et signal qu'ils
sont prêts à se reproduire
lorsque les femelles arrivent à leur
frayères elles vont creuser un nid dans
le gravier avec leur queue et pendre
jusqu'à 4000 ou le mâle va libérer un
nuage de l'étain
lorsqu'ils reviennent du Nord du
Pacifique jusqu'à l'emboucheur du
freezer sur les 4000upondus seulement
une dizaine de saumons ont survécu et
sur ces 10 à peine 2 en moyenne
parviendront à frayer pour perpétuer
l'espèce
c'est ainsi que s'achève leur long
voyage les socailles comme les autres
saumons du Pacifique meurent après avoir
frayé et le cycle continue
cet automne à peine quelques stocks sont
arrivés c'est qu'au bord de la rivière à
Doms on se croirait en plein été
on est le premier octobre assis ici
anticher les gens sont au bord de la
rivière en sandales ce n'est pas normal
l'automne se fait attendre
l'impact des changements climatiques
préoccupent John Raynolds
ce scientifique dirige une des plus
importantes chair de recherche sur le
sommet du Pacifique
jusqu'à tout récemment il était le
président du Comité sur la situation des
espèces en péril au Canada
c'est un poisson d'eau froide et on sait
maintenant que le réchauffement des
océans un impact négatif sur lui alors
il doit non seulement survivre et
réussir à se développer suffisamment
le problème de la température de l'eau
quand vient le temps de remonter la
rivière
un bon niveau de la rivière conjugué à
une température de l'eau qui monte
au-dessus de 20 degrés Celsius c'est
très problématique
on est très préoccupé parce qu'il se
passe dans la rivière Adams même si ça
va mal à certains endroits du globe ici
on pouvait toujours fêter au Quatrans
cette belle grande montaison de saumon
alors ce qui se passe cette année me
rend plutôt
en plus des changements climatiques les
sommets du Pacifique font face à de
multiples défis
la pollution la dégradation des bassins
versants les prédateurs la pêche et la
contamination par des parasites
issus des fermes d'élevage en mer sont
autant de menaces qui les guettent tout
au long de leur vie
c'est pourquoi les scientifiques sont
inquiets la grande montaison de 2010 sur
la rivière Adams a été exceptionnelle
avec le retour d'environ 3 millions
800.000 secrets en 2014 seulement
707100 revenus et en 2018 ce nombre a
chuté à 535 000 saumons rouges
il y a une lueur d'espoir dans les
derniers jours des socailles ont été
aperçus par pêche et océan Canada en
aval de leur parcours migratoire sur la
rivière Thompson et dans le lac
chouchoir
des endroits où ils peuvent se réfugier
en profondeur là où l'eau est plus
froide
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour ses
chercheurs de l'Université Simon
freescer spécialiste des écosystèmes où
vivent les salmonités le groupe a fait
le trajet de Vancouver jusqu'à la
rivière Adams
ils ne sont pas ici pour effectuer des
recherches mais pour le plaisir
d'assister pour la première fois à cette
incroyable spectacle
on vous lèvera faire la plongée en apnée
pour voir les saumon rouge dans leur
habitat naturel c'est une enfer les
attraper en patois à la pêche mais c'est
vraiment le fun d'avoir dans leur
environnement
la première tentative est loin de donner
les résultats attendus
qu'on aimerait en voir normalement c'est
la grande montaison à laquelle on
assiste tous les quatre ans
ce n'est vraiment pas leur jour de
chance à peine quelques saumons se
pointe le bout du crochet
S c'est plus profondes puis c'est
attendre la pluie puis le bon moment
pour offrir
ce serait intéressant de revenir si
jamais il y a plus d'eau et qu'elle est
plus fraîche pour voir s'il y a
davantage de poissons
les socailles arriveront que si la
remonter cette année les yeux sont rivés
vers le ciel
pleuvra-t-il enfin le mercure va-t-il
descendre le retard est préoccupant car
les saumons jouent un rôle important
dans la santé des écosystèmes
on se croise les doigts pour qu'il soit
simplement en retard mais j'ai un
mauvais pressentiment ils ne seront
peut-être pas aussi nombreux qu'on le
voudrait
suis-je optimiste quant à leur retour
ici oui je le suis dans les deux
prochaines semaines peut-être et c'est
ce qu'on dit aux gens peut-être
les saumons soccailles sont des poissons
adaptés à l'eau froide mais l'automne
dernier en raison du temps anormalement
chaud en Colombie-Britannique leur
montaison se fait attendre pourtant
l'apport de ces poissons à la santé des
écosystèmes riverains et crucial car
aussi étonnant que ça puisse paraître
lissements contribuent à nourrir la
forêt
deux semaines après le début du festival
retour au bord de la rivière-adams après
votre départ les saumons sont finalement
rivés
comme la température de la rivière
baisse nous voyons chaque jour de plus
en plus de poissons si bien qu'il y a
maintenant des dizaines de milliers de
saumons dans la rivière Adam
mais on est encore loin du compte
c'est difficile de prédire ce qui
adviendra du saumon ça dépend tellement
des conditions météo
on verra toujours de grandes montaison
mais les poissons reviendront-ils encore
par million
je ne suis pas très optimiste
la migration par millions des saumons
rouges est au centre de la vie de la
Première nation c'est quoi pump
ces membres se réunissent depuis la nuit
des temps au bord de la Riviera pour
célébrer leur retour
est très important pour les sacs web
nous sommes les gardiens des terres et
des eaux
fait partie intégrante de notre culture
de nos rites de tous l'écosystème
fournissent des nutriments à la rivière
toutes les espèces dépend du saumon des
oiseaux jusqu'au grizzly
on aurait pas survécu à nos hivers il
nous garde en vie comme toutes les
espèces sur Terre
les premières notions connaissent depuis
toujours la contribution importante des
saumons à la santé des écosystèmes
depuis quelques années les scientifiques
arrivent aussi au même conclusion
par exemple cette scène peut sembler
désolante pour le commun des mortels
partout des carcasses à perte de vue
mais pour les chercheurs derrière ces
images de saumon en décomposition se
cachent un phénomène inusité et positif
c'est qu'ils sont programmés pour mourir
après avoir frayé quand il remonte la
rivière c'est un aller simple et le
cycle recommence
l'estomac du Pacifique peuvent gagner
jusqu'à 99% de leur masse corporelle
durant leur séjour en mer
ils font alors le plein de nutriments
marins qu'il ramène ensuite sur des
milliers de kilomètres jusqu'à la
rivière où ils sont nés
en quelque sorte les forêts qui longe
les cours d'eau
dans ses arbres géants que vous analysez
vous y trouverez des nutriments qui
proviennent des saumons
autour des rivières abondantes en saumon
40 à 80% de l'azote qu'on trouve dans
les arbustes et les arbres provient de
l'océan comment se transfert de
nutriments des poissons vers la forêt
s'opèrent-ils
les carcasses des poissons sont dévorés
par une multitude d'insectes qui
allaitent se font manger par des
poissons
par des ours et des loups qui ne les
mangent pas au complet si bien que les
restes fertilisent les végétaux
puisque les insectes se nourrissent des
plantes et que les oiseaux gobent les
insectes nous avons d'ailleurs constaté
qu'il y a plus d'oiseaux près des
rivières ou le saumon à Bond
il y a une quinzaine de poissons juste
ici
quoi en surface
tout ce qui tombe plus de la moitié de
leur nourriture glissent des feuilles
des arbres comme des fourmis par exemple
les scientifiques vont de surprises en
surprises dernièrement John Lennon et
son équipe ont voulu mesurer l'impact
des saumons sur les écosystèmes
forestiers d'une façon pour le moins
original c'est la rivière à dams qui
leur a servi de modèle
la rivière Adam c'est vraiment unique
parce qu'on peut y observer cette
incroyable cycle qui fait que les
saumons reviennent par millions tous les
quatre ans et on voulait voir si leur
impact était visible depuis l'espace
les chercheurs ont analysé des images
prises à partir de l'espace de 1984 à
soit sur une période de 36 ans
nous avons pris des images satellites de
la rivière Adams et extrait des données
quant à la productivité ou à la couleur
des arbres
nous les avons comparés avec des images
modèles pour voir si les nuances de vert
étaient liées à l'abondance des saumons
je doutais que ce serait visible mais
oui après une année de grande montaison
des socailles le vert des arbres qui
longeait les rivière était plus prononcé
l'augmentation mesurée est de 1% jusqu'à
100 mètres du rivage cette découverte
sera utile aux chercheurs
l'étude met en évidence une des
nombreuses interactions qui existent
dans l'écosystème du saumon c'est très
important de documenter ces phénomènes
afin de comprendre comment ces
écosystèmes se comportent face au
changement
le décompte non-officiel de pêche et
aussi en Canada l'esprit âgé que pour
2022 la migration de retour ne
dépasserait pas les 500 000 sekaïs sur
la Riviera d'hommes les immenses montais
ont du passé sont peut-être désormais
derrière nous
on aurait pu la traversée simplement en
marchant sur leur dos
et regarder aujourd'hui il n'y a
pratiquement plus rien
ici le saumon disparaît que va-t-il nous
arriver donnez-moi
et beaucoup de gens s'en rendent compte
je garde espoir que le socaï sera nous
surprendre et même son entrevoit
quelques embellis il faut garder le cap
et mettre sa protection au sommet de nos
priorités
[Musique]